he has been dominant yeah he's gone six
plus in every start he's given up two or
fewer in five of his six starts this
year including his last timeout at
wrigley field last wednesday crawford
stands in and off we go shooting the
first pitch to third and turner one
pitch and one out an offense that has
been the biggest issue now this has been
their best hitter mitch haniger they do
have a little pop every once in a while
basketball swinging a fly ball into the
gap in right center feeling deep taylor
going back to the wanting track to the
wall goodbye baseball mitch haniger the
mariners lead the dodgers right away
here in the top of the first how about
that one out bases empty one-nothing
seattle kyle lewis swung out and missed
strike three bueller has his first
strike strikeout of the night kyle
seeger left-handed batter a little bit
high and a foul tip into the glove of
smith for strike three so bueller
strikes out too but he gives up the long
ball to hannigarh it's the 29 year old
out of japan you say kikuchi who had a
539 era over his first two big league
seasons but they say oro he's looked
like a different guy he's attacking with
conviction
showing a motion and his last two starts
he's got a 193 era face bets here
swinging a ground ball two operative
third right there kyle seeger toss
across in time to get bets one pitch and
one away for usa here he is short stop
corey seeger swung out on a hard hit
ground ball out to the second baseman ty
francis shallow right field with a shift
on picks it off the turf to throw to
first in time to get seeger and there's
two outs and again you say up to his old
tricks over his last
two outings keeping the ball on the
ground and that's what he's got to do to
win ball games here's third baseman
justin turner fastball swing and a miss
for strike three that's it for turner
and the dodgers here in the bottom of
the first inning what a start for
kikuchi there's strikeout number one
with two strikeouts over the first
inning we'll face france a 236 hitter
strike three on a generous outside
corner he says i'll take that greg
gibson throwing balls and strikes
tonight he's got his third already four
consecutive strikeouts uses the slider
to get this one that was really good he
is locking in on that corner dylan moore
with two gone and the base is empty
that's chopped up the middle lux ranging
to his right throws on the move a nice
play and a one two three second for
buell you say kikuchi retired the
dodgers in order in the first smith
muncie and taylor here in the second
swats went into right center field he's
the first base runner of the game for
the dodgers so smith aboard with the
lead-off single his first base have been
max munson muncie takes low for ball
four adding to his major league lead in
walks in the first two reach in this
second inning brings up who is probably
their hottest hitter and chris taylor
swing adam is for strike three and you
say kikuchi needed a strikeout here in
the bottom of the second and he gets it
his second strike out of the night
strikes out chris taylor in a high
heater swung on in a fly ball into right
field toward the line going back hanniga
is there back pedals out to his right
and he makes the catch
so two on and two away for the dodgers
here in the bottom of any number two a
big second out for you say kikuchi
that'll bring up young second baseman
gavin lux swung on on a fly ball into
right field hannah ground the run
reaches out slides and he makes the
catch
holy smokes what a play by mitch hanigar
down that right field line you say takes
his hand off waves at the hanniger says
thank you very much bigger left-handed
batter looking out at walker butler the
runner on and one man out is a high lift
into the corner carrying back kyle
seeger welcome to dodger stadium the
mariners tag buelter for the second time
tonight this time a two-run smash a
little bit of a glance at his younger
brother corey's three nothing mariners
two outs base is empty for max muncie
kirkuchi since muncie's walk back in the
second and he has retired eight straight
maxwell swings the silver hammer and the
dodgers get on board
it is now three to one brings up mitch
team leader in batting average home runs
and ops and runs scored he's added to
that total tonight cut
deep out to left and mitch haniger goes
yard for the second time tonight in los
angeles it's the mariners third homer
against walker bueller
it's 4-1 of the sixth inning what a
night for you kikuchi 11 strikeouts for
you say kikuchi against the reigning
world series champion dodgers it's an
all-time career best for you
one of his best starts in a mariners
uniform comes to los angeles the bases
are full of dodgers and mookie betts is
coming up one out bases loaded
[Applause]
strike three called it is so far in
[Music]
unbelievably bad call in a huge
situation for a team
that needs one of their offensive
leaders to come through and this is an
area the dodgers just continue to
struggle they're over six tonight with
runners in scoring position seeger this
year where the bases loaded two for
three with a two-run single it's a
one-run game two out in the bottom of
the seventh the hard throwing ready
raphael montero on deface justin turner
swung on and missed struck him out
fastball
and that'll do it for the dodgers in the
seventh and for the first time justin
turner is going to wear the golden
sombrero with four strikeouts two out
single taylor katie gets hit
gavin lux gets a chance here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dodgers have flipped the script
as they have now taken the lead
gavin luck's first home run of the year
a three-run shot with two outs in the
bottom of the eighth now kelly jansen on
to try and close it out
he's gonna have to earn it
lewis and seeger do up the one-two
[Applause]
now
cut on in this one
6-4 game ninth inning here comes kyle
lewis hanson ready for the 3-2
he's got back to back
to open the nine
he's locked in i don't care if he goes
to three and oh he's locked in and now
the mariners are down to their final out
here in the top of the ninth inning
dodgers lead it six to four
pumped up
this should do it
left side of the infield corey seeger
the dodgers win at 6-4 getting two in
the seventh and three in the eighth